let's think back to tuesday's
lesson we had a look at equations of
this form
and tried to work out what the shapes
were being we had to do some fairly
um fancy geometric reasoning to get
there so let's try and review
uh what what is this shape right um what
kind of
what's like what's the general way you
describe the locus what kind of shape do
you get
it's a semicircle right so this equation
it generates a
semicircle
and one of the things that we noticed
was that if you have
any two points right there are two
semicircles
that both kind of could work right so
how do you work out which one it is
comes to the next word right which way
do you go
you go anti-clockwise right so it's a
semi-circle that runs
anti-clockwise and it's defined
its start and its endpoints are defined
by those two things that you see in the
quotient there
of the argument z1 and z2 it's kind of a
giveaway because the way i've written it
but which one comes first
zed one the one on the numerator that's
why i called it
z1 so this is kind of the way that you
would articulate
it for me i always want to see like each
part of the equation you've been handed
it tells you something instrumental
about the equation so
where do you get each of these bits from
how do i know
it's a semicircle which part of this
equation tells me specifically it's a
semicircle
half high half pi right over here right
this is the part over here that tells
you
it's a semicircle
going from right to left you can see we
read off the start and the end point or
the beginning and the end points
from our numerator and our
denominator right and then lastly like
why is it anti-clockwise and not
clockwise do you remember what the
reason was
why why do we go in this direction why
is the bias
toward that wave rotation
that is the way we measure all angles
arguments on the complex plane so in
fact it's really implied when you see
arg it's like bam you've already started
talking about anti-clockwise
so it's kind of convenient actually that
these four
things i'm looking for they kind of
appear in alphabetical order
left to right you're going
anti-clockwise you know where you begin
and end and you're going to get a
semi-circle
okay great so let's try and review
because from there you remember
we didn't just um we didn't just say oh
that's nice we had to graph it and we
had to actually know
you know boundaries and things like that
so you had to get the cartesian equation
which is what you need these things for
right
so interval a b is the diameter of
this semicircle and if interval a b
is the diameter then you can tell me two
important things which we need to know
to get the cartesian
equation that correspond to these if a b
is the diameter then what's
half of that distance it's the radius
very good
that's obviously once you square it is
going to go on the right hand side
of your equation your cartesian equation
and then the midpoint of a b if a b is
the diameter the midpoint is the
center fantastic and you need both of
those things to get your equation
now what we want to do is to go further
in this and some of you actually
actively asked this question last lesson
which was delightful right
what if this angle up here what if the
angle is not
pi on 2 what do we do with that right
what shape
does it provide to us now there are some
spoilers on this [ __ ] i tried my best
but
not all of them i want us to think about
what we're trying to do here being
as a generalization of the result we
just got right
if we change this angle it's going to
clearly be related right we're not
fundamentally changing what's going on
but we're going to modify it in some way
so i want to give you a little
comparison to this right you've actually
been doing this
for years we used it this morning
what is this
this is pythagoras theorem and what it
does is it relates
the three sides of a right angle
triangle
right hypotenuse two shorter sides okay
but then what we did was and i'm
thinking it's
around year nine and ten um depending on
where you were in the grade at that time
what we did was we then said actually
you know what
pythagoras theorem it kind of works
even for non-right angled triangles you
just kind of fiddle with it
a little bit even non-right angle
triangles have a relationship between
the longest side and the other two sides
you just need to
modify based on the fact that the right
angle means you don't get exactly
pythagoras theorem
what do you get what's the modification
factor if you change this to a
non-right-angled triangle so remember
i'll give you clues starts with not
highlighting it starts with a 2
2 a b
cos c and because there's a cos in there
we call this
the cosine rule right because the cosine
rule is just pythagoras theorem just
amped up to work on anything it's a
general version
of pythagoras's theorem and of course if
you put in if you put in
pi on 2 into your angle and make it a
right angle triangle what's cos pi on 2
again
zero it's zero so you just get
pythagoras theorem again right
so that's what we're going to try and do
with uh this equation here we want to
think about what if you had like pi on
four or pi on three
so on your computer can i ask you to at
the bottom
of the canvas page and i asked you to
prime this up before
on the bottom of your canvas page
don't film me now mobile data i'd love
you to click on the desmos link right at
the very bottom we looked at desmos last
lesson
but there's a different uh page that i
want you to open for that
okay um and if you've got it could you
just spin your laptop around just so i
could see
it's loaded up successfully i want to
make sure it worked that i gave you the
right link does anyone got there
[Music]
does anyone got there is it working i
just quit fantastic okay anyone else got
there
okay all right
so what we're going to do here is
and i i'm just going to put out there
i'm going to do the long version of this
offline so if you are curious for like
the details underneath what's going on
i'm just going to
bring you sort of to the second last
part of this i want to give us the
circle
geometry property just like last time we
looked at the angle and a semicircle
remember that it's pi on two right
um we're going to look at the angle
sorry the circle geometry property that
gives
us what what sort of locus we're going
to get this time right
so on this diagram here what we're going
to do is measure some angles right
so on the left hand side up in the
corner you can see you've got a bunch of
controls
maybe you've used this before maybe you
haven't because we're looking at angles
here i want you to click
on that angle button over there in the
top left and it'll you'll know you did
it right because
desmos will then say well do you want to
measure an angle and you've got to
choose
three points to define the angle
a leg a vertex and another leg right and
that'll give you what the angle is
i'd love to start off by measuring this
blue angle can you do that with me
so you're going to start with this black
vertex over here
on the left then you're going to go up
to the the vertex of the blue angle
and then you're going to come right down
to the bottom right hand corner and you
should get something looks like that
did it work yeah i'm getting some nods
okay fantastic wonderful
so we got 60 degrees i couldn't find a
way to make this um
make it go radiance but that's fine i'll
take degrees okay so 60 degrees you've
got pi on 3 over there okay
now i then want you to go ahead and
measure the red angle so
same deal go ahead and click on angle
over there and then
leg a vertex and then
another leg so what have you noticed
it's not a coincidence red angle blue
angle they are
equal to one another now here's the fun
part and this is why i asked you to get
onto desmos rather than just draw
this though you will actually draw it on
your page i want you to take
either the blue or the red coordinates
the ones up the top
and i want you to take them click on
them with your mouse and move them
somewhere they are actually variable
points and when you do so you should
notice
let's see how how stubby my fingers are
you'll need to click on select by the
way to do that in the top left hand
corner
when you click on select if you take one
of these you'll notice
that you can move that red point or
indeed you can move the blue point
anywhere that you like and so long as
you're on the circumference
on that side you're going to get 60
degrees
unless by the way there is a place you
can move it on the circle you don't get
60 degrees anyone notice that where'd he
go
yeah very good you go to the other side
you're like oh oh it's 120 degrees what
is that by the way what's the
relationship
between 120 and 60. yeah they added 280
is supplementary right
not a coincidence by the way okay now we
can um
we can state this we can state this fact
in words right so just come back to that
piece of paper that you had
before right you can see we've got a
diagram here
that shows what's going on you've got
this angle up here in the corner
and so long as both of these angles
reside i'm going to do my best and maybe
you'll actually find this easier with
your pencils and stuff like that
so long as both of those angles reside
in this
same kind of area up here
right goodness me that's messy i'll fix
it in a second
okay so long as those angles reside in
the same space up the top
by the way does anyone know what is the
um what is the name of this shape that
i've just
colored in orange it starts with an s
it's called a segment very good
so so long as your angles sit in the
same segment
they are going to be and you should add
this to your diagram
they're going to be equal right if that
angle over there was theta
this angle over here which is in the
same segment should also
be theta and if you want to you can make
your diagram a bit busier you can draw
another
angle that's in the same segment like so
you can put them any way you like so
long as you're in
this orange region and defined in that
way
they're all going to be theta so the
wording that we use
for this is that and this is really
important you should jot it down
angles angles in
the same segment
are equal
okay you may also see this same circle
property
named as angles standing on the same arc
angles standing on the same arc it's
exactly the same idea put your eyes up
again and have a look at the diagram
right
can you see all four of the angles that
i've marked as theta you can kind of
imagine them as
legs standing on top of let me highlight
it
neatly so i can this arc over here on
the bottom do you see that
can you imagine them standing out and
you sort of like you know put your feet
shoulder length apart right so this is
the arc that they're standing on and all
those angles up there
all equal different words same property